it was the Takeover overtaken by drama
and doubt and now after weeks of
speculation Elon Musk is pulling out of
the 44 billion dollar deal to buy
Twitter this is the letter which may
ignite An Almighty legal battle musk
accusing Twitter of misleading him over
the sale the social media giant withheld
information he says about the number of
fake or spam accounts on the platform
but some claim this deal was doomed from
the start and musk is simply looking for
an escape hatch but maybe he'd want to
buy this thing and uh you know now that
he's you know struck a deal at 44
billion dollars which probably nobody
thought he would be able to succeed at
he probably just decided okay uh didn't
work out it's driving Tesla stock down
you know 30 40 percent so you know this
isn't really working out the way I
thought so I'm out of here
the world's richest man the 51 year old
is used
to use some course but Twitter are not
going to
let the company's chairman says the
Twitter board is committed to closing
the transaction on the price and terms
agreed upon with Mr musk and plans to
pursue legal action to enforce the
merger agreement
since announcing the bid in April musk
has used Twitter to Mark every Twist and
Turn he promised to address what he said
was a lack of free speech on the
platform but he was tight-lipped about
the legal battle yesterday instead
tweeting memes from the cartoon
SpongeBob SquarePants and film Anchorman
the questions now are why exactly does
he want to abandon this deal and what if
anything can Twitter do to stop him it's
likely to be decided in the courts and
it won't be cheap for either party
Martha callner Sky News Los Angeles